Molo ka mana tёw їwekїtomo?
I am an Indigenous woman
from the Amazon rainforest.
I don't look Indigenous, do I?
"You're Indigenous?" people always ask me.
But don't worry, I get that a lot.
I bet you expected
an exotic Indigenous woman
with a painted face
and feathers in her hair.
Probably a bow and arrow too.
Well, today I won't be talking
about the looks of Indigenous people.
Today I want to talk to you
about Indigenous perspective,
what that means and how it can help
change this world.
So I come from Suriname,
the only Dutch-speaking country
in South America.
It is also known as the greenest
country in the world right now.
You didn't know this now, did you?
(Laughter)
Suriname is still 93 percent
pristine forests,
with a population
less than 600,000 people.
I come from the south of Suriname,
near the border with Brazil
and French Guyana.
I am from Amazonia, I am Wayana.
I was born in a small settlement
with 150 Wayana people.
My start in life was complicated.
You see, in our culture,
when your partner died,
you had to wait at least two years
before you started a new relationship,
my grandmother told me.
When my father's wife died,
he decided that he couldn't wait anymore
and took a new lover, my mother,
who was at that time only 16 years old,
and got pregnant.
Also, certainly in our culture
and maybe in yours too,
it is considered shameful
when you get pregnant
and not living with a partner.
So because of that,
my mother tried to abort me
multiple times.
All, which as you can see,
didn’t succeed.
(Laughter)
It did leave me with some health problems,
but I survived.
I was called, for a very
long time “anolїtpё”,
which literally means trash.
My father denied that he was my father
because of pressure from his family.
But luckily, my mother's parents
decided to raise me.
Even so, it was hard
as I was constantly treated as trash
by the rest of my community.
So when I was five years old,
my grandparents,
especially my grandmother,
she decided that it was
in my best interest
that I go to the capital of Suriname
to get an education,
to make something of my life.
So I packed my little suitcase.
I stepped on a plane
with a family friend I barely knew,
[and] for the first time in my life,
I left my village.
I remember being determined
at only five years old
that I was going to go back to show them
that I was more than trash.
This family friend of ours and his wife,
they became my foster parents.
And I have been the second daughter
that my foster parents always wanted.
And my foster family are from a tribal
people called Saamaka,
and they live as Indigenous people.
Here's the thing.
Even living far away
in the capital of Suriname,
going to non-Indigenous school,
surrounded by non-Indigenous people,
I was still Indigenous.
My worldview and my DNA,
were still shaped by that legacy,
by those traditions.
Because every summer holiday,
I could go back to visit my grandparents
and learn those amazing
cultural aspects of being a Wayana.
So yes, I had the best of both worlds.
I have the best of both worlds.
And in both worlds I was
and am still Indigenous.
What I came to realize
is that even far away in the capital,
I was privileged to live
in the greenest country on Earth
because of Indigenous peoples,
because of Indigenous guardianship.
We are the protectors of the forests,
so we protect this world.
Eighty percent of all
the world's biodiversity
is within Indigenous territories.
Let me repeat that
in case you didn't get that.
Eighty percent of all
the world's biodiversity
is within Indigenous territories.
The Amazon, where I come from,
is home to more plant and animal species
than any other terrestrial
ecosystem on this planet,
including 40,000 plant species,
2,200 fish,
427 mammals.
One in ten of the world’s bird species
live in the Amazon,
which has been inhabited by Indigenous
people for thousands of years.
Now, try to imagine,
when non-Indigenous people
come to my community
to try to teach us about sustainable
forest management or conservation.
(Laughter)
We are the forests,
we breathe the forests.
We cannot even translate "sustainable
forest management" in our own language,
because to us,
it's simply a way of living.
We are the protectors of the forests.
It is because of us that the world
has any forests left to protect.
I believe, we believe,
that protecting the planet
should be done by Indigenous people
that has been doing so all along.
That is why the work that I'm doing
with my community is so important.
I'm no longer trash.
I'm recycled.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Yes, I'm recycled.
The Amazon, where I come from,
it's so unique.
And sometimes we as human beings,
we try to change things so fast,
and we try to put our individual needs
ahead of the collective good.
And because of this change
that's going too fast,
we ultimately cause destruction
that will destroy us all.
So today, here I am to teach you guys
how you and I can protect this world
the Indigenous way.
What is Indigenous guardianship?
There are five key words
that we can all learn from
from Indigenous perspective.
The first one is responsibility.
Responsibility towards our territory,
where we have been living along
for thousands of years
by taking good care of it.
We feel responsible for Mother Earth.
So can all of you.
Demonstrate the responsibility
through action.
Do not be afraid to say:
"I don't know, let's find out together."
Attend activities hosted
by Indigenous communities.
Lead by example.
Talk about decolonizing
and indigenizing education
with colleagues.
Connect with Indigenous people,
businesspeople, artists,
speakers and craftspeople
in your work and your life.
Learn about responsibility
in the context of our existence.
The second "R" is respect.
We need to respect each other.
Just like I respect your Western world,
you should respect my world.
Respect is a word
that is a concept that feels
often abstract than action-based.
It can be very difficult
to find specific examples
to demonstrate what respect is.
We can all become guardians of this world.
Respect our way of living.
Respect our knowledge.
Respect our way of decision making.
Respect our Indigenous people's
cultural integrity.
It has worked for many centuries.
The third “R” ...
relationship,
the third “R,” relationship,
is about Indigenous people’s relationship
with their ancestral land.
Engaging with indigenous communities ...
it’s very important to understand
the nature of the relationship
among ancestral lands,
cultures and spirituality.
Engaging in this way
requires long-term commitment
and mutual learning.
A relationship based on mutual respect
eliminates the tendency
to exert power over another.
It is something we can all learn,
practice and improve.
Reciprocity is the idea of embracing
that giving and receiving
connects people, beliefs and action.
It is not all about the money,
and those who have resources
don't have all the power.
They shouldn't have all the power.
Giving and receiving
from the Earth endowments
is also part of a virtuous
healing principle.
In this way,
even the "poorest" Indigenous community
can give back to all of us.
The last “R”, redistribution.
Redistribution of our ancestral lands.
My people, for instance,
we don't have any legally
recognized land rights.
Because our ancestral lands
have been distributed to third parties
as concessions for mining and logging.
Eighty percent of the world's
remaining biodiversity
is within Indigenous communities,
as I mentioned before.
And it includes places that are essential
for our global climate,
our freshwater and food security.
These are places vital to all of us.
Help in securing
Indigenous people's land rights,
join us, support us in our fight.
Making sure that Indigenous people
have the means to protect their lands.
We can all benefit from that.
Make sure that Indigenous people
have the economic power
and the cultural independence
so they can be successful in protecting,
defend and govern
their ancestral territories.
So, initially,
when my community
threw me away as thrash,
they just thought that they
were doing what was right.
They thought that they
were doing what was best
because they learned those things
from Western power,
Western colonial powers and norms.
And then they learned better.
They learned that I also
have important and unique values.
And guess what?
We are all doing the same thing
with our planet.
We are throwing it away,
we are trashing it.
Maybe only for a while,
because we didn't know any better.
Just to realize how much
we all need the Earth
because it uniquely contributes
to our lives, and it sustains us.
A healthier relationship is key.
A healthier relationship
with Indigenous peoples is key
to a healthier relationship
with the planet
that we as Indigenous people protect.
And then we can all be recycled.
(Laughter)
And we can thrive and survive
on this planet that we call Earth.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)